The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: Let's take
a look at storyboard 14,
where I discuss the Q cycle.
If you look back at my previous
lecture in which I introduced
the respiratory
apparatus, you'll
see that there are three points
in the electron transport
chain, at which protons
are translocated
across the mitochondrial
inner membrane,
into the intermembrane space.
The three sites are complex one,
complex two, and complex four.
If your entry point
for the electrons
is a pair of electrons
at NADH, you'll
translocate about 10 protons.
This generates the
electrochemical gradient
that will be used in complex
five, the F naught f1 synthase.
And the energy released in
proton translocation back
into the cytoplasm, eventually
will be used to synthesize ATP.
At this point, I'd
like to take a look
at the hypothetical
mechanism by which proton
translocation into the
intermembrane space
happens in complex three.
At the outset, let me say
that the mechanism here
is different from the
mechanism at complex one
and complex four.
And I'll also mention that other
organisms have found other ways
to solve this problem
of translocating protons
into the intermembrane space.
Let's look at panel
A of storyboard 14.
At the upper left, we see
coenzyme Q in its quinone form.
In this form, it's
a taxadiene dione.
It's one of our co-factors.
And we've also referred to it
in the past as a mobile electron
carrier.
In that regard, it falls into
the same grouping of molecules,
such as the NAD plus, NADH pair.
The squiggly line
at the lower right
corner of the quinone molecule
depicts isoprene units.
Actually, there's a
series of about six to 10
of these isoprenes
in the Q molecule.
These probably
facilitate association
with hydrophobic regions,
such as regions in membranes.
The structure of
coenzyme Q allows
it to pick up electrons one at
a time from an electron donor.
And deliver them one
at a time to a place
where the electrons
are going to go.
That is an electron recipient.
This panel shows the
step-by-step mechanism
by which electrons,
one at a time,
can reduce the oxidized form
of coenzyme Q. Called Q here,
or the quinone, to its fully
reduced form QH2, also known
as the hydroquinone.
These electrons come from
complex one, or complex two,
or another membrane bound
entry point for electrons
into respiration.
The first electron converts the
quinone Q to the semiquinone
radical.
The semiquinone will then pick
up another proton and electron
to form the fully reduced
species, the hydroquinone,
or QH2.
The hydroquinone QH2 is
fully loaded with electrons.
The fully reduced hydroquinone
will next deliver its two
electrons to complex three.
The technical name
of complex three
is coenzyme Q, cytochrome
c oxidoreductase.
This name gives a hint
that the electrons
are going to pass from
coenzyme Q in its reduced form,
to an oxidized form
of cytochrome c, which
is also non-covalently
associated with complex three.
Let's look at panel B. A
single molecule of QH2,
the hydroquinone, contains
two electrons that
are going to be transferred
to complex three.
One electron is going to
reduce iron three to iron two,
in a first molecule
of cytochrome C.
And then the second
electron is going
to be used to reduce a second
molecule of cytochrome c.
It's convenient to break
this overall reaction
scheme into two parts.
I'll call them cycle
one and cycle two.
In cycle one, the first
molecule of cytochrome C
is going to be reduced.
And then in cycle two,
the second molecule
will be reduced.
I've further broken down
the cycle into eight steps.
At the upper left
of complex three,
you'll see a site that
I've marked with an x.
This is an iron
cell for protein.
This is going to be that docking
site for QH2, the semiquinone.
Sometimes it is called
the Q delta site.
The reduced quinone, QH2, gives
up two protons and one electron
to form the semiquinone
radical, Q.minus.
The electron in
step three goes over
to reduce ferric ion
to ferrous iron, that
is iron three to iron
two in cytochrome c.
As I mentioned
earlier, cytochrome c
is another one of our
mobile electron carriers.
It's going to float away
and go off to complex four.
At this point in step four
B, the semiquinone radical
is going to give up
its second electron
to cytochrome bL,
which is a constituent
of the complex three.
From the standpoint of
coenzyme Q, at this point
it's lost both of its electrons.
It has been converted to
the fully oxidized form
Q, as depicted in step
four A. The electron
at cytochrome bL flows
into cytochrome bH.
And from there, it
will subsequently
flow into a molecule of the
parental diquinone Q. The one
electron reduction of
the diquinone Q, results
in the formation of the
semiquinone radical,
once again.
This is at position Y--
the way I've drawn the complex
three in panel B. Position Y
is also called the Qi site.
At this point, the
semiquinone radical
will just stay where it
is for a few minutes.
We'll pick it up again in the
second half of the Q Cycle.
To summarize what happened in
the first half of the Q Cycle,
two protons have been
translocated from the matrix
into the intermembrane space.
And one electron
has been transferred
to cytochrome c, which
then translocates
across the outer surface of the
mitochondrial inner membrane
to complex four.
At this point, please
look at panel C.
Now we're going to take a look
at the second half of the Q
Cycle.
At the bottom of
complex three in step 1,
you'll see the orphaned
semiquinone radical
that we just created.
Keep in mind that we
are going to come back
and use that radical
in a couple of minutes.
So bear with me.
At step two, we see
a second molecule
of the hydroquinone, QH2,
inside the mitochondrial inner
membrane.
We're going to borrow this
molecule for a short time.
And then we're
going to restore it.
So this QH2 is,
essentially, catalytic
in the overall reaction scheme.
In step three, we see that
this borrowed molecule
of the hydroquinone, QH2, gives
up two protons and one electron
just as we had seen in the
first half of the cycle.
You will note that
we are reducing
a second molecule of cytochrome
c, which is then going
to go off to complex four.
And we're also going
to be producing
a second molecule of
coenzyme Q, the fully
oxidized form of the co-factor.
In step four B, the
semiquinone radical, just as
happened in cycle
one, will give up
its electron to cytochrome bL.
The electron will then
go to cytochrome bH,
and then will flow into
the semiquinone radical
that we had left over
from the first cycle.
This radical exists at site
Y, or as I called it before,
the Qi site of complex three.
The reduction of the
semiquinone radical at step six
is concomitant in step
seven with the acquisition
of two protons from the matrix.
This series of
reactions, ultimately,
results in restoration
of QH2, the semiquinone
in the mitochondrial
inner membrane.
At this point, we have
restored the molecule of QH2,
at step eight, that we
had borrowed, initially,
at step two.
The second cycle
has also produced
net Q, the oxidized
form of the co-factor,
which is now free to go on
to complexes one and two,
and to pick up more
reducing equivalents.
Just looking at the second half
of the Q Cycle, what we see
is that we've translocated
another two protons
into the intermembrane space.
And we have transferred a
second electron to cytochrome c.
So cycle one and
cycle two, each,
result in the translocation
of two protons
from the matrix to the
intermembrane space.
And each results in the
transfer of one electron
to cytochrome c.
Looking at the whole Q Cycle,
that is cycle one and cycle two
together, we get a pair of
electrons that enter from QH2.
Four protons are translocated
into the intermembrane space.
And two reduced molecules
of cytochrome c,
which then migrate
to complex four,
where they'll be later oxidized.
Let's turn to storyboard
15 and panel A. In panel A,
I'm showing another way
to look at the Q Cycle.
I'll emphasize that this
is not as chemically
accurate as the two step process
that I showed you previously.
And I'm not going to
discuss it here further.
Nevertheless, I think
that this presentation
makes it relatively
easy for you to see
the overall stoichiometry
of the Q Cycle.
Let's now turn to
storyboard 15, panel B.
In the way of a high-level
review of electron transport
so far, electrons from
nutrient oxidation
have been deposited into the
electron transport chain.
The transfer of
electrons to oxygen
resulted in energy that
is used to power pumps--
pumps that pump protons into
the intermembrane space.
We've looked at the Q Cycle
as one example, of several,
of how protons are pumped.
It took energy to create
this proton gradient.
When we release
the proton gradient
by allowing the protons to
flow through the ATP synthase,
we're going to be able to
use that energy in order
to accomplish the
otherwise energetically
uphill phosphorylation
of ADP into ATP.
Now let's look at storyboard
15, panel C. This panel
shows the F naught F1 proton
translocating ATP synthase,
also known as the ATP synthase.
To put things in
perspective, at the top
is the intermembrane
space, which
is where the protons
have been translocated.
In the middle is the
mitochondrial inner membrane.
And at the bottom is the
mitochondrial matrix.
Because we've pumped protons
into the intermembrane space,
its pH is about three
quarters of a pH unit
lower than the pH of the
matrix of the mitochondria.
Proton flow is going to
be regulated in response
to physiologic needs.
I'll talk about that regulation
and how it occurs later.
For now, however, let's look at
protons flowing through the F
naught F1 complex.
Let's imagine that
the broken line
indicates a channel, through
which protons will flow.
Other structural
features include
a shaft, which I've
indicated as gamma,
and a ring, in which
the shaft is embedded,
which I've indicated
as the C-ring.
When protons flow, both
the shaft and the C-ring
will move, as you'll see,
in a clockwise rotation.
At the bottom of the
overall apparatus
are three alpha and
three beta subunits.
These are not going to rotate.
That is, they're
going to stay fixed
in position while the C-ring
and the gamma subunit rotate.
The beta subunit
contains a site x,
which is going to be the active
site for conversion of ADP
plus inorganic phosphate to ATP.
I've drawn a little elbow on
the bottom of the gamma subunit.
Let's imagine that
protons are flowing.
And the flow makes that
subunit spin around.
And further, imagine
that the elbow is
bumping into the active sites--
that is, the x sites.
There are three of
the x sites, one
on each of the b
subunits at the bottom
of the overall apparatus.
Imagine that the energy involved
is translocated from the elbow
to the active sites.
And that's what's going to
help us align ADP and Pi,
to make the overall
chemical reaction favorable.
That is a hypothetical,
but not far fetched way
to think about the
way that ATP is made.
Let's now look at panel
D. The current view
is that the active site
oscillates among three
different conformations
during the time
the protons are translocated.
These three
conformational states
are referred to as O for open,
L for loose, and T for tight.
In the open state, nothing is
present at the active site x.
The conversion of
open to loose is
concomitant with the binding
of ADP and inorganic phosphate.
As protons continue to
flow, the loose site
is converted into
the tight state.
The energy associated with this
conformational change results
in the alignment of the
inorganic phosphate,
such that the conditions
are now favorable
for it to phosphorylate
ADP and form ATP.
Further proton flow results in
the tight state being converted
to the open state, which
ejects the formed ATP out
into the mitochondrial matrix.
So at each cycle, of
open to loose to tight,
a molecule of ATP is made.
And then it is ejected.
This goes on again,
and again, and again.
That's the overall mechanism
by which ATP is synthesized.
At the high level, proton
flow results in the movement
as the turning of a rotor.
It is a lot like
a water wheel that
might drive the rotation of a
millstone, that grinds grain
into flour.
The rotation of the
shaft provides energy
to bump into the
x sites, resulting
in the conversion
of a first subunit
to the open conformation,
another subunit
to the loose state, and
a third subunit to tight.
Then the process
starts over again,
with each cycle producing
one molecule of ATP.
As one final point--
a point that explains how
this process is regulated.
Proton flow results from
the binding of ADP--
that is, ADP.
This will become
important in a few minutes
when we talk about how the
whole system is regulated.
Now let's look at storyboard 16.
Let's look at all four
panels, panels A through D.
In the last part
of this lecture,
I'd like to talk
about how respiration
is coupled to the TCA
cycle and glycolysis.
This is really the
first time in 5.07
that we're going
to see the beauty
of coordinated
pathway regulation.
I'm going to use a
physiological scenario in order,
hopefully, to make
it all make sense.
In this scenario, imagine
that you're being chased down
the street by a dog.
In order to start running
away from the dog,
we're going to need some ATP
that's very quickly generated
from glucose by glycolysis.
The TCA cycle is also
going to be operative,
along with a pathway
we haven't seen so far,
fatty acid oxidation.
In both cases, the TCA cycle
and fatty acid oxidation,
reduced electron carriers
are going to be produced.
They're going to give up their
electrons to the electron
transport chain.
Ultimately, to reduce oxygen
to water and with concomitant
pumping of protons into
the intermembrane space,
resulting in the
lowering of the pH--
that is, acidification of
the intermembrane space.
As I mentioned
earlier, that flow
of protons through
the ATP synthase
is triggered by
the binding of ADP
to the x site on the beta
subunit of the enzyme complex.
As your muscles are working
hard and you're running away
from the dog, the
concentration of ADP
in the mitochondrial matrix
is going to be increasing.
Thus, proton flow is
going to be initiated.
As you run more and
more, the protons
are depleted from the
intermembrane space.
It's not known exactly how
this reduction in proton
concentration results
in accelerated
movement of electrons through
the electron transport chain.
It's tempting to
speculate that one or more
of the reductase centers, within
the electron transfer chain,
may be pH sensitive.
Let's imagine that
that is the case.
So let's imagine that
the raising of pH--
that is, the decrease in
hydrogen ion concentration
in the intermembrane
space, results
in the facilitated flow of
electrons from complex one
or complex two, to oxygen.
Next, let's look to the far
left at the bottom of panel D.
As you draw more electrons
into respiration,
NADH is going to be
converted to NAD plus.
It's important, now, to remember
that NADH feedback inhibits
any step at which it's
produced in the TCA cycle.
Thus, as you're running
away from the dog,
the NADH concentration drops.
And that means
that there's going
to be less inhibition of
the steps at which NADH
is produced in the TCA cycle.
Thus, looking at the
big picture, the binding
of increased concentrations
of ADP to the ATP synthase,
over on the far right, results
in the activation of the TCA
cycle and other
metabolic pathways that
will result in the
delivery of more electrons
through the electron
transport chain,
in order to allow
you to continue
to run away from the dog.
Next, let's imagine that you've
been running for quite a while.
And let's look at complex
four, where oxygen is bound.
Sooner or later you're going
to be becoming oxygen limited.
You're going to be
panting heavily.
This means that electron
flow from a reduced electron
carriers to oxygen is
going to slow down.
As we become more hypoxic,
respiration starts to fail,
but hypoxia
dramatically increases
the levels or activities of
the enzymes of glycolysis.
Thus, glycolysis
will switch over
to becoming our principal
ATP generation machine.
As we increase the
rate of glycolysis,
the flux goes from
glucose to pyruvate,
but the pyruvate
can't be oxidized
because it can't
enter respiration,
because we don't have enough
oxygen present in order
to oxidize it.
So what happens is we
activate lactate dehydrogenase
to convert pyruvate to lactate.
Conversion of pyruvate to
lactate has two consequences.
The first is that conversion
results in the conversion
of NADH to NAD plus.
Remember, that this is
the lactate shuttle.
And that NAD plus is
now available to allow
glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase
to continue processing
molecules of glucose into ATP.
A second consequence
of activation
of lactate dehydrogenase
is the fact
that lactate spills out
into the blood, where
it acidifies the blood.
The pH drops.
Now let's think about
what the consequences are
when the pH of the blood drops.
I want you to think back to the
lectures in which JoAnne talked
about cooperatively, the
Bohr effect, and the affinity
of oxygen for hemoglobin.
JoAnne told us that protons
are heterotropic allosteric
effectors that, effectively,
loosen the affinity of oxygen
for hemoglobin.
So as you're running
away from the dog,
glycolysis becomes
the main pathway.
You produce a lot of lactate
that goes into the blood.
The pH drops.
Oxygen lowers its
affinity for hemoglobin,
and thus, becomes more available
for the pathway of respiration.
Oxygen is now back in the system
and binds to complex four.
So you kind of get what we
could call a second wind that
allows you to continue
using respiration
to run away from the dog.
In other words, you've
adapted to the stressful state
and are now able to
continue running.
Now let's put it all together.
A dog starts chasing you.
Your readily available energy
reserves, and free glucose,
as well as glycogen,
will produce
rapid ATP that will get you
moving away from the dog.
Additionally, respiration will
be contributing lots of ATP
to allow you to escape the dog.
And as you're running,
ADP concentrations
will go up inside
your mitochondria.
That will, basically,
release the proton gradient,
allowing the ATP synthase to
work very quickly and very hard
to make a lot more ATP.
NADH concentrations
in the mitochondria
will drop with
physical activities.
This helps boot up the
dehydrogenases of the TCA
cycle.
They become less inhibited.
Your TCA cycle will
accelerate, in order
to produce more reducing
equivalents to power
the electron transport chain.
All of this will continue until
your oxygen becomes limiting,
then respiration starts to fail,
but the hypoxic state turns up
the activities of the
enzymes of glycolysis,
thus glycolysis accelerates
and helps accommodate.
But pyruvate, at the
end of glycolysis,
cannot be further oxidized
because there's not enough
oxygen. It has to be
converted to lactate.
The lactate acidifies the blood.
The Bohr effect causes
the release of more oxygen
into the blood, making it more
available to complex four,
in order to reboot the
electron transport chain.
Overall, this is a marvelously
regulated physiological system
that seems to have evolved in
order to promote our survival.